I'm a New York City beautiful New York
City today I'm letting Twitter run my
day the first things first advocate
bagel
come on post office don't do that New
York City the Big Apple you know I've
actually been in New York a few times
but I I don't do a lot of exploring I've
always been here for work so I'm having
Twitter make all my decisions and
hopefully I'll learn more about New York
first things first though where should I
get bagels so I asked Twitter where I
should get bagels is it
Tomkins bagels so I'm going to put out
four options for bagels I'm gonna let
Twitter decide I let them choose between
plain garlic pumper nipple rubber nipple
butter nickel and chocolate chip got my
bagel although it wasn't chocolate chip
bagel they were out of that so I got a
garlic bagel oh man I got scallion a
bacon spread I'm keeping it real keeping
the real real pigeons eating pizza
pigeons eatin pizza I saw some pigeons
eating pizza this morning yeah he's
great New York they love a good slice
bail oh very garlicky
fgfs that first initial shock this is
very very good often it's humid and hot
in New York I need some new clothes okay
so I got my crew with me we're gonna go
out in New York and see where we go next
great yes elevator from the future so I
asked yesterday for a bunch of people to
just send me a bunch of things to do in
New York I shoot it out lots of tweets
came back oh there's a farmers market
going on but those are things those are
things let's do the polling for five
minutes it was very close between
flowers fruit and bread you want to get
some raspberry yeah
oh well I'm getting raspberries you can
get raspberries in me great we refer you
from Egypt
you know I've met to it she treated me
earlier she's vacationing from Egypt
yeah we don't have raspberries in Egypt
we only have the frozen one
Oh real fresh raspberries no you've
never had Russian are you kidding oh my
god this is oh my goodness
I desire as berries BAM we also bought
some edible flowers because those seemed
fun first so we're gonna try raspberries
in edible flowers but let's just do this
grab a raspberry so as you can hear at
this point of the video we don't have
good sound I don't know what happened
I'm editing it right now anyhow she
tries a raspberries she loves them
obviously they're great I love him too
she talks about how they're minor for
dad and a tree Hey it's a very cute
story that I unfortunately don't have
the sound for it and then we stuff a
bunch of flowers in our mouths and I gag
on it alright moving on so now we're
gonna go buy clothes we're going to a
place called Scotch in stone close
enough sketching soda
taking off my clothes okay so I'm in the
changing room and I tried on two outfits
I'm going to tweet out pictures of those
see what people going on see which
outfit they want me to buy I also have
to make sure that they have these shirts
enlarged because I tried on mediums on I
in a medium here plan
so I just got my new outfit I look so
fine I'll be sure to my crotch
I look so fine and now we're gonna pick
out food so we asked the internet if we
should get Pizza Street meat or a hot
sub sandwich so we're gonna let them
vote for five minutes and then we're
gonna go eat that's how it's going we're
going down the train to get to the pizza
place
huge aisles all around the whole
training oh yeah nobody's like huh
let's go illusion this place is darling
what are we in wow he's got a nice place
look at all those bombs okay can we get
four slices of cheese look at that
Oh all on top of itself so we just
finished having pizza at two slices of
cheese and now we're actually taking a
break from the Twitter adventure I gotta
go to Central Park and sit with a cup of
money so somebody on Facebook live can
win $200 pretty good pretty good
welcome everybody again to cup oh my eye
I tried to be on a boat it was enough
internet on the boat not a banana boat
so I just decided out come up here and
this is where I'm stationed with my
water bottle of money what are you gonna
say what do you say don't worry
what do you say you say a thing give me
the money
nananananananananananana no give me that
coffee
you've done it here are your $200 hi
we'll see you next time on Oh
Hey so we're leaving Central Park we had
a good time with a couple money took a
little bit longer than expected so we'll
go back to Union share so go back to fir
I'm just tired I'm just tired you know
I'm just tired having a hard time but in
New York City pretty building boobies
potato police code all right we're back
in Union Square I'm gonna go get a hot
dog for some one suggestion and then
someone else suggested I asked people
about sausage those seem to work hand in
hand let's do it
grab a hot dog I just mustard please how
do you like these sausages good agreed
back of the space elevator back in the
space elevator I meant to turn the
camera on myself but I'm just going the
door how was your day
we're back the final question is am I
gonna go see Book of Mormon with Eugene
and Ned or should I go see Hamilton with
Zack you guys got a vote okay bye
butter is not that actually yeah you
know Hamilton one but I can't afford
that so we're booking Mormon sorry guys
we're Book of Mormon see you later
these are keys